when you have and it great only thing
what I've put on the board on the bottom
left it actually has a whole bunch of
solutions an infinite number in fact
right for example give me a number any
of you like three if I double it I get
six there's a pair of solutions like
well one solution that's your numbers
give me another number
high-five you don't let you get 10 is
another solution these both work I can
get on it on forever for this equation
here and a whole bunch of solutions so
that's what happens when we draw right
the graph of an equation is a picture
that shows every possible solution
all of these x equals three x equals
five x equals 800 x equals negative two
all of them are on the picture okay
which is why the errors are on the ends
of the lines because this blank goes
forever the graph an equation is a
picture that shows every possible
solution of that equation have a look
you can see let's put some numbers on
here so you can see what's going on
right if i say the x equals 1 right when
i double 1 I get 2 and so you can see if
you look up if I even like to draw a few
dots here you come across there too
so that point right there it's a
solution X is 1 Y is 2 great but it's
not the only one every other point along
that line think about the one as an
infinite series of like a whole bunch of
ants or just zoomed out so all you see
if the line right I if I move over just
a little bit you can see if x equals 2
what's Y it's gonna be equal to all
right I can draw it all the way up
that's also a solution every dot I place
on this line even the leader ones that
are like between numbers there are all
solutions they're all valid does that
make sense
so when you just just solve it like I
give you equations all the time in a
sense all right and you come up with a
number at the other end but if there's
not just one number if there's a whole
bunch of them you can't write every
single one you'd be there forever so we
drove it that's why we try these things
now let's make the most
that's when we solving simultaneous
equations what does simultaneous mean
like actually when it means yeah at the
same time it's like okay I'm gonna fire
the gun you're gonna run simultaneously
at the same time is the perfect phrase I
substitute therefore if they at the same
time we are trying to find a solution
that doesn't just work for one of them
but works for both at the same time
that's what we mean by simultaneous so
we don't want a solution that just works
for one equation like those guys we want
a solution that works for both equations
okay the solution works for both not
just like okay cool if I put these in
that'll be true but as an example here
huh I'm one both of these to true at the
same time pair of numbers I can put in
and they both just magically click now
remember I said every point on this line
is a solution to this equation so if I
want a solution to both equations then I
want to look for a point that's on both
graphs so if I've got a point on this
graph gonna solve this equation if I've
got a point on both graphs it'll solve
both at the same time both
simultaneously
okay now he's ready you're gonna need to
help me I've already redrawn the same
graph over here wife goes to X we can
see okay
what does this look like what can you
tell me about it
okay so the first thing I could do is I
could draw up little table guys in fact
I'd like us all to briefly do this won't
take long
I'm going to do $3 each what X numbers
would you like me to test give me 3
minus 1 0 1 would you fine
okay let's give them a quick cut so if I
go y equals 3 take away negative 1 3
take my negative 1 double negative it'll
be full right okay that's one value how
about y equals 3 take away 0 3 and y
equals 3 take away 1 okay I'm sensing a
pattern now does that make sense now I
can take each of these and I can say hey
those are points and I'm gonna put them
onto my onto my graph let's just really
briefly do that negative 1 4 so I come
to the left and I'm gonna go up there
here's my first poem this one here
where's that where would you describe it
verbally it's gonna be on the y-axis
very good and I'm gonna go up 1 2 3
units on there okay and I've got one
more to go everyone I'm gonna be looks
like there okay so you can see here I
could draw a line that connects all
those dots it's gonna look yeah there we
go okay I could make it straight up but
that's what I'm offering
okay table dollies with Sanders
suggestion just as a side note I could
have done it one other way I could have
said if I switch this around like that
that's actually a form it's a form we
learnt last week I'm not sure if you
remember it it looks like this y equals
MX plus B do you remember that is it
ring a bell why do the M and the B when
you see the equation like that gradient
gradient and Y in dessert write the
vertical intercept do you see how it
works by the way um the gradients is
what's the great yeah there's this
number right for the X and
yeah one hiding there right maybe one
does that make sense
look it's it's dropping it's decreasing
that's a thumbs-up what about this time
oh look there it is right there I'm even
gonna label it okay so it checks out
either those would be fine I'd get the
same one so what's the solution to these
simultaneous equations at the same time
do I not run color do I not want this
guy right do you see is a point on both
lines that means he's a solution to both
equations does that make sense
points on the line are solutions all
along points on both lines that's a
solution two simultaneous equations
that's why yesterday when we were
looking at production costs right and
profits from selling the book right we
wanted to find that point where they met
where it solved both of them at the same
time we called that the break-even point
so this this is doing with this with a
picture okay this is what we're focusing
on in 12 and yes okay I already wrote
down two questions yesterday but I'll
back them up again just in case you this
death this is Aikido I'm just going to
tease a little bit of what we're gonna
do in the future what we did this right
it kind of depended on this graph being
decent right like if it was a bit messy
or if it was like in-between and it
wasn't a nice neat point it'll be really
hard to read that off women maybe harder
you precise okay
so graphically solving this is just one
way it's the first tool so you get a
picture of what's going on but it's not
gonna end there when we lose the
interest see course we will learn better
ways of solving these artistic ways more
precise ways where is it don't even need
a picture okay